il rugit imposant tous deux lames
d'acier
ce gardien semble protéger ses
congénères depuis le 7 octobre l'animal
s'expose à rambouillet pour la treizième
biennale de la sculpture rambouillet
situé dans au milieu d'une forêt dans
lequel on a beaucoup d'animaux il ya une
tradition animalière à rambouillet
depuis fort longtemps et c'est cette
tradition là que nous avons souhaité
conserver
avec cette exposition liée aux animaux
en particulier
de l'animal domestique l animal sauvage
des oeuvres discrète d'autres monumental
la biennale rassemble un véritable
bestiaire où toutes les techniques sont
représentées
quarante trois artistes exposent plus
d'une centaine d'oeuvres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
nous ouvrons notre biennale à la fois
aux artistes amateurs et professionnels
donc il n'ya pas de discrimination entre
les deux et ce sont des artistes qui
viennent de
d'ile-de-france de rambouillet d'île de
france mais aussi de province on a des
gens qui viennent du sud de la france de
marseille on a des artistes qui viennent
aussi de l'est de l'ouest de la france
et on a aussi quelques étrangers qui
expose les animaux sont à rambouillet
jusqu'au 21 octobre avant de prendre
leur envol
[Musique]